こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんは滑舌の
悪い人見た事ありますでしょうか
僕もぉ人並にかつじぇつが
悪いんです
けど世の中には滑舌がもっともっと悪い人
たくさんいると思います
あのお笑い芸人の
ローソンをローションっていうぐらい滑舌が悪い方もいると思うんですけど
世の中には不思議がいっぱい
ペーロン
解読不可能
やべぇ奴だこいつ
今のは聞き取れましたか
今のは若干難しかったですね
誰？
ﾇﾍﾞﾁﾞｮﾝﾇｿﾞｼﾞｮﾝﾍﾞﾙﾐｯﾃｨｽﾓｹﾞﾛﾝﾎﾞｮﾋｰｲﾋﾋﾋﾋﾋﾋ
キンフンパーリー
待って下さいよもう一回お願いします
あのこの口の動きちゃんと
キンフンハーリー
パーリー
おお
やっぱり僕らも最初戸惑ったんですけど
もう別に何もないよね
だんだんと聞き取れるようにはなってく
慣れでしゅね
慣れか
何て？
わかんないスカ？
死にそう
ちょっとね今彼の
おお凄いです素晴らしいですね
これはなかなかの難問ですね
逆にこのおにふ君の
理解できれば大抵の
もう最悪理解できれば動物とも会話できる気がする
気持ちを読み取ってあげることが大事
ンン〜
ちね💢
これ本当にわかってたら凄いと思います
へぇ〜そういうもんなんだ〜
ｼﾞｼﾞﾝ
ｼｷﾁ
やばい俺分かっちゃった
ﾇﾍﾞﾁﾞｮﾝﾇｿﾞｼﾞｮﾝﾍﾞﾙﾐｯﾃｨｽﾓｹﾞﾛﾝﾎﾞｮｲﾋｰｲﾋﾋﾋﾋﾋﾋ
だ〜い好きなのは〜血〜溜まりと金〜
言いなれてるので（殴
皆はわかったかな
あっ
視線の先に注目
おいお前ら八つ橋かよ
すいません雑にやりすぎました許して下さい何でもしますから
は？